this was Alex Murdoch's emergency call
oh no hell no okay and are they
breathing no ma'am better whiskey Fox
whiskey Mike both gunshot wounds to the
Head the man who's called police has
killed his wife and son and he's
covering it up
he was the high profile lawyer they
seemed a happy family embeddied in High
Society
the picture unraveled shockingly with
the murder of Maggie Murdock and
youngest son Paul I am going to testify
in South Carolina Courts they knew the
murdochs is a powerful legal Dynasty
m-u-r-d-a-u-g-h they knew this model
good morning as the accused did you take
this gun or any gun like it
and blow your son's brains out on June
7th or any day or anytime
no I did not to the court he brought
denials and to the criminal
investigations distress
well the charade was undone by a
Snapchat video
Modoc said he hadn't been near the
murder scene at the time of the killings
but this is a Snapchat video filmed by
his son Paul minutes before he was
killed Alec Murdock is heard in the
background shouting come here Bubba
come on
[Music]
not the first episode of notoriety to
embroil the model
four years ago 19 year old Mallory Beach
was killed when Paul Murdoch drunk
crashed the family's boat
but then somebody I know that's what it
is I like more dog pointed to that as a
reason for someone to commit murder but
prosecutors said he did it that he'd
been caught stealing Millions from the
family firm and that he killed family
members to gain sympathy and halt
investigations
this case has prompted fresh police
inquiries concerning an influential
family including the death of her
housekeeper Gloria Satterfield
she died in 2018 after a fall at their
home deemed an accident at the time
in small town South Carolina there are
questions beyond the courtroom over one
family's power and its past
James Matthews Sky News